[Music]
giant monsters and Nile ating
skyscrapers colossal lizards roaring
winged Titans as they battle to the
death what could possibly go wrong the
answer so very very much
Godzilla commits so many game design
sins that they become impossible to
count but the greatest horror of them
all is that such giant monsters could be
so boring
it all starts with god of destruction
mode as the king of the monsters you
march out of the sea and begin your
rampage with the epic goal of destroying
the power generators in each level all
the while a g-force operator shouts
military orders for all the good it does
she also announces opportunities for
ground crews to collect data at
particular points that requires you to
click a stick at which point the camera
zooms out to show you a cinematic view
of the creatures flailing
[Music]
you're playing is a giant monster but
simultaneously as the defense forces
it's a bizarre narrative contradiction
that culminates when your military
contact mourns her losses while
triumphant music plays and you're
granted a victory but put aside the dumb
storytelling since it's the least of the
game's problems instead focus on how
leading Godzilla into the fray is like
steering a backhoe through an aquarium
he's heavy
sure but he's in no way fun to maneuver
and so you charge forward swing your
tail and bash buildings to keep yourself
occupied as you trudge towards the
generators over and over again you do it
until you finish the campaign 20 minutes
or so later and realize you have to
repeat it many many times over to unlock
upgrades and other Kazu which you can
also lead into battle the game is built
around unlocks and upgrades which come
at a horrendously slow pace the menus
seem to offer a lot of options but don't
let them fool you Godzilla is very light
on content that it's sold at full retail
price is ludicrous and insulting
other monsters appear to do battle with
you of course the games best moments
aren't related to gameplay but to the
stirring visuals of seeing Rodin or King
Ghidorah appear and clash with
spacegodzilla such events may mirror
Godzilla films but actually taking part
in them reveals a laughable array of
awfulness balance is one of the biggest
problems some monster combinations are
hysterically inept such as when you take
control of King Ghidorah and spam a
diving attack to victory without taking
a lick of damage if you want to be super
cautious force your enemy against some
invisible wall and watch them float into
the air as his animations struggle to
complete ends like several monsters
Batra can surge through the air to
safety then return for a hit-and-run
attack exploiting your opponent's slow
turning speed facing a larva stage
Mothra as an air bound Batra meanwhile
is one of the most tedious and broken
things I've ever done in a video game
that's because only my strongest attack
which is governed by a heat meter was
the only consistent way to do damage
it's boring on top of boring from here
the problems just pile on sometimes the
game Auto targets your enemy even when
you're faced in another direction and
try to charge away you face Super x
aircraft in the campaign but some
attacks have Godzilla clipping right
through them without doing damage and
should you be tempted to fight one or
two players in versus mode crippling lag
and timeouts might have you reaching for
the power button that's a shame because
the most enjoyment I had with Godzilla
was winning a three kaiju free-for-all
with only a smidgen of health remaining
keep in mind however that I didn't earn
that victory
I just knew which attacks to spam and so
it goes in this overpriced and
unattractive game whose finest mode is
one in which you place unlockable action
figures on a diorama yes looking at
static monster figures in fighting poses
is a lot more fun than actually
participating in battle the worst news
of all is that if you want more figures
you have to play the game and
that's just not worth all the yawns
[Music]
you
[Music]